team liquid cs go team has a long and
proud history this is absolutely perfect
he's got the perfect angle except on the
other side and he goes
they're major finalists grand slam
winners and have been considered na's
greatest roster for years you see double
smokes in the same place they're simple
just jumping casually to the side he's
going to fall down and get right there
what is it from simple are you serious
what is that you can't do that simple
that's not allowed this is not fpl this
is a major but despite their incredible
legacy team liquid has experienced some
of the worst defeats in csgo history
here he comes once again the first base
is the trend he's going to hit the
ground there's cold
wow that's jumping double from cold what
is it going on right now how does he do
this corner safely velocity with your
play unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartment
now as one of north america's last
top-tier teams liquid is carrying the
hopes and dreams of an entire region i
think it's gotten to the point for our
team that we had to manage our
expectations that we weren't what we
used to be but in order to succeed
they'll need to overcome a curse that's
been plaguing them for years
[Music]
the liquid curse began at mlg columbus
2016. it was the first major played on
north american soil and coming into the
event liquid was one of na's greatest
hopes he's gonna be able to look over he
will there right there he tries to go
for it he gets a kill and simple
actually no getting up both to kill the
third one as well we're just two kills
away flushing going down and now it's
all on jw all alone with 18 seconds
ladies and gentlemen liquid they will
have made it through into the quarter
finals here at the mlg columbus major he
goes down to hiko and there it is 22 19.
lick where they do it cs go has been
dominated by european teams since it
came out so when liquid faced off
against brazil's luminosity gaming in
the major semi-finals fans thought that
this was na's moment and at first things
were looking pretty good as simple as
teammates now start to clamber their way
up the slope into the a bomb sign an
oppressive force has found its way into
that a site in the name of liquid and
simple again he gets another entry frag
what the hell is he going to do
once again liquid
completely crusher bombsite
and all the momentum is swinging their
way
liquid dominated luminosity on mirage
all the way up to map point this is not
the luminosity we won the hearts of fans
over the recent weeks and months this is
this is a ghost but then something
happened that would forever change the
course of cs go history here he comes
once again the first base is a trend
he's going to hit the ground there is
cold oh
wow that's jumping double from cold what
is it going on right now how does he do
this
call to save luminosity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments they needed a huge play but
that was something i'm never going to
see ever again coldzera hit the most
absurd series of jumping noscopes that
the counter-strike world has ever seen
for context according to tests done by
youtuber dinos warleaf cold had less
than a two percent chance of hitting
just the second shot it was a one in a
million play that should have never even
been possible and at that exact moment
team liquid's curse was born luminosity
won the next six rounds to force
overtime and before liquid could even
try to recover the map was over hiko
making its way around the smoke was
found that he will spot taco but that's
it luminosity with a comeback from 1510
an amazing play from cole with the awp
all the way back into overtime into a
victory going into map 2 it looked like
liquid had regained their composure and
they secured map point yet again but
then
the unthinkable happened hiko taking a
lot of damage there so is coal down the
31 all the flash from a teammate so good
but simple gets the trade
taco with a hedge on a simple five
seconds left to plot the bomb adren will
get a frag but there's no time to plant
the bomb he's in ct spawn dan and we are
gonna go to overtime so close and yet so
far liquid somehow choked even harder
this time losing 13 of the next 14
rounds to get knocked out of the event
for luminosity it was one of the
greatest comebacks in cs go history but
for liquid and their fans it was the
most heartbreaking match of
counter-strike ever played
by the time the next major rolled around
everyone figured that liquid had to
learn from their failure in columbus who
still has a pistol he cannot play this
he cannot fade it out nitro his presence
known at long and guardians aware of it
that's the chance to advance
man oh man what a round to pull this
back and liquid are going in the semi
finals they looked unstoppable at
cologne 2016 taking out navi and fanatic
and giving us some pretty iconic plays
along the way
double smokes in the same place they're
simple just jumping casually into the
side he's gonna fall down and get up
right what is this
simple are you serious what is that you
can't do that simple that's not allowed
this is not fpl this is a major
liquid were playing some of the best
counter strike their fans had ever seen
and became the first na team to play in
a major grand finals but standing
between them and victory was the exact
same roster that knocked them out of the
previous major a lot of damage being put
into cold sierra as well 19 seconds and
now finally sk are going to man up and
try and see if they can get out here
hiko picking up a kill and it's all down
to cold zero 10 seconds jumping back
onto the side he has to stick to plant
he can't even fake it and actually he's
going to be successful in that now the
deagle goes for the fight takes out nico
and now it's a one-on-one all versus
open jdm goes down go syrup that's the
quad kill oh liquid one last attempt
here at the next playing close to the
train he's gonna help be held up by fur
and there's fnx finally coming through a
spray and takes down a kilter now elise
the last man left then he dropped 16
severin seven an sk picking up the first
map here in the grand finals
it's straight into drop with the bomb
and fnx in position taz doing i'm proud
there is another spray in fnx all three
and now the molotovs are finally gonna
burn him alive and that's up to elise
six seconds here the bomb plant isn't
gonna happen oh what no the fire oh it's
still gonna happen fur
taking out elise that would have been
the round one more second how could it
be real
he has to go and fight and they're
getting close he has the spray coming
through he takes out first as well but
he's down to 12 health and now it's just
all in the details easy for sk to pick
it up here trying to walk through the
smoke but it's just not gonna happen sk
gaming second major championship in a
row they are your winners
the brazilian roster seemed to be
liquids kryptonite and after the n a
squad's poor showing in the final the
team imploded
simple left hika was benched and liquid
entered a rebuilding phase they even
brought in sk's former coach zeus to
help but despite winning some small
events liquid were unable to secure any
big trophies in an attempt to change
things up liquid traded taco and zeus
for stewie2k while we really do think
that stewie is the right fit for us and
we think that it can lead to
championships
the origin of this trade is because zeus
and taco asked to be traded the former
major winner spent the last year in
brazil playing for the very team that
terrorized liquid back in 2016 and
bringing young stew back to na turned
out to be the best decision liquid could
have made he's got the c set and he's
gone it's all on the jw smoked away and
it's done finally
finally liquid get their notch on the
grand slam and stewie is the answer it
turns out after all
he consents players on the other side
there's gonna be a kill for twist surely
he gets the first is this where it ends
aloe in the three verses one
but he's got the kill
and liquid habit they've got the
championship they've got masters and two
in the intel grand slam
oh my god eminem get a one versus three
with 19 seconds
unbelievable scenes here ladies and
gentlemen team liquid are your season
nine pro league champions if it's rpk
this drop it could be in serious trouble
that should do it there we go it's team
liquid and that's what it means to them
after years of disappointing results
liquid looked unstoppable in just 63
days they managed to secure the intel
grand slam becoming only the second team
to ever do so but this legacy is
permanent they have done but no one
might ever do again until grand slam
team liquid
it looked like liquid finally broke
their curse but in september 2019 it
came back with a vengeance
after dominating the counter-strike
scene for nearly five months liquid were
the favorites going into the berlin
major but when the event finally got
underway everything fell apart it's all
on this a two on two the last couple of
seconds left the flashbang to try and
buy some more time they don't have a kit
right now i don't see how they can get
this defuse there's device and this is
after that fateful loss to astralis
liquid hasn't been able to recreate that
success that they saw in the summer of
2019 and after losing nitro
things went from bad to worse this hard
fight this long fight it might be
drawing to an end and not in favor of
the liquid side down goes the liege and
it's all on twist 20 seconds molly on
him he's burning
i think losing nitro actually hurt us
more than we expected
just losing him he was a big he was a
glue for our team he was a big part of
you know being friends with everybody
and you know he was like the middleman
the team keeping the team together and
he played a big leadership role as well
and
losing him
we lost like a key player of our team
that pretty much understood the
foundation of our game and you know the
philosophy that we play and we're losing
a big voice to help us in the middle of
the game or you know someone that knows
you know every role in the server by the
time esl pro league season 14 rolled
around there was no doubt that the curse
was back it's stewie here with the
opener they're trying to chase fallen
down but stewie's got his back it's the
beginning of the end and it's all the
awps canadians burnt out can't find a
thing still we have fallen making it
happen make it team liquid be that
semi-final he's three fresh as good as
he's been as much as he's given us
this is a team liquid victory teed up
he's on for a third now i did as well
refresh how are you making this happen
grim his heart's racing his heart's
beating but refresh can't find him it's
your guessing game stick on the bomb
grim doesn't swing he thinks it's a fake
refresh with all five and we're going to
overtime liquid were just one round away
from securing a quarter-finals win
against heroic but once again
they choked
stewie burning alive and it's all eyes
on fallen one on three the bomb out on
shore he can't find a thing he's trapped
in a prison of heroics making
trapped in a prison in the mind that
it's heroic
despite liquids heartbreaking losses
true fans still believe in csgo's last
remaining north american hope that's
pretty much it you know you don't know
what to expect when you watch team
liquid you know you sometimes you expect
them to be the worst and all of a sudden
you see them performing better than they
have been in the past few months and
they start you know reeling you in
they've proven that curse or not they
can still be the best team in the world
i think it's gotten to the point for our
team that we had to manage our
expectations that we weren't what we
used to be but we definitely can be what
we used to be if not better and for us
we only have one goal really like to be
the best team in the world and once you
get that taste of being the best team in
the world when you're when you were
there you're gonna want it back and
that's the biggest drive for us you know
i think we're just a team filled with
competitors and we only like to win and
losing takes a big toll on us and
you know our biggest goal is just to
keep improving and take it every step of
the way and yeah it hurts watching them
lose but that's because everyone knows
what liquid is capable of
we know they can beat some of the best
teams in the world they've done it
before and we all want to believe that
they can do it again
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock